previously on TV sins I call him girder
meep morp zeep
reading yeah what are we now Gareth
glorified red shirts how Dumber Rickon
company not to think that the terminus
cannibals didn't have a contingency plan
for people trying to attack them when
they open that compartment based on what
I've seen the idea that rick has kept
this many people alive for this long is
crazier than the idea of a zombie
apocalypse also you're just now looking
up I get that as an audience we don't
know where that sound was coming from
but you should have known that
immediately also also since the terminus
end game is to peel and eat these people
then why not just kill them all here
instead of taking the chance of a
successful revolt on the way to the
slaughter trough Eli Roth's The Walking
Dead totally get the need for labeling
your human parts containers but would
you really take the time in the
apocalypse to go full Kinkos on your
label making holy the show knows nothing
about creating suspense the scene is way
scarier if we see Rick and Daryl trying
to squirm out of their mouth gag and
hand ties while we hear the drilling
sound in the background not knowing what
that entails showing this it's just
gross and frankly silly also watching
this guy clean up the little bit of
blood spatter while the dissection is
still taking place it's hilarious when
doesn't seem very cost-effective no
reason to do this until they're done
with his body you're just wasting
cleaning solution at this point I can't
imagine that it's exactly replaceable
it's the apocalypse
pretty sure aunt Fanny is no longer in
business well I guess it's a good thing
that the show regulars are really far
down in the queue so that they have time
to get out of it while giving the show a
chance to provide the grisly violence
you SiC crave show steals the blood down
the drain shot from psycho but refuses
to shoot it in black and white and use
chocolate syrup to not offend my
delicate sensibilities hey
you're shot count who nothing like a
good fake out and we all know this show
would never killed one of our favorite
characters this way
Jaime could you imagine also bureaucracy
ex machina so you go into the woods with
a bag and come out without it wasn't was
this intimidation play always the plan
here
did he just happen to be here before
they battered through the lineup and got
to Rick and thought maybe he might ask
Joe seems to want to have it both ways
for effect but not on my watch that's
what I'm gonna use to kill you
hero states his intention to kill their
captor in a specific way even though
they are currently powerless but we all
know what's going to eventually happen
exactly the way they called it cliche
jeez how many Dave's x-wing ACCA's can
you have in one Episode this is worse
than when someone in the mystery movie
keeps putting the poison cup to the lips
but not drinking just drink the poison
already also that gunshot made you stop
what you were doing there were two
gunshots before this a person in panic
wrote away with you on this wall instead
of go away or stay out they should have
just finished it protuberance of the
flesh and completed the ridiculousness
Carol is supposed to be the smart one
here right so why when faced with an
oncoming horde of sauntering walkers
does she decide it just hide and wait
you could literally outrun them by
piling up your pace - mole Walker what's
this nonsense I'd also like to take this
opportunity to say that zombie should
trip more if this goo crew had the
dexterity and visual acuity to clear
these tracks then shouldn't they also be
able to open doors fire guns and give
half decent hand jobs the Friends of the
chick with the sword and the kitten who
you just happened to mention at the
exact moment we were sneaking up on you
for full convenience points Carol does
some viscera camouflage here but why
exactly did she have to put it on her
face again is it a visual but they're
zombies like hmm this creature smells
like ghosts but the face looks too clean
also if this works so well why doesn't
everyone do it all the time do they not
have the guts I don't have any friends I
mean I know people they're just [ __ ]
I stay alive with oh I am 100% noticing
the time go by and it is the farthest
thing from funny
liar
I'm not saying Carroll couldn't aim the
fireworks to hit the exact spot she
needed for that explosion to go on but
I'm saying Carroll couldn't name the
fireworks to hit that exact spot she
needed for the explosion to go well
maybe your friend the director said
let's have your character to gum during
every senior in it'll make your acting
choices look like even more of an
[ __ ] you stay here but don't kill the
people that could get loose and kill you
just let them roll around for a minute
and loosen their zip ties if you ever
being pursued by a zombie I'm going to
go ahead and suggest you not try the
frantically scooting backwards while
lying on your back method of escape
stand up man what are you a pill bog
maybe Carol could fool one or two of
these things but the idea of her walking
through a pack of them without a single
bit of a breeze taking some of her human
smell to their zombie nostrils is about
the bull bull the show has had me
swallow we got those people out still we
are it's kind of yeah thank God they
never go against this way of thinking
it's not like they will ever sneak into
a room of humans while they're sleeping
and stab them all in the head glad that
never happens
Rob Zombie is the walking dead
convenient perfectly placed mirror is
convenient ah southern conquer your
signs they were real it was a sanctuary
really rich again Carroll has not
hesitated to kill anyone and she's
letting the mom from pet cemetery talk
why is the scene not here neither am i
okay but what about Joaquin Phoenix was
he ever really here we interrupt the
sterols and feral darryl reunion with
Carolyn to ask if carol was still in
peril why and when before reuniting with
Darrow did she clean up her face and
apparel to come with me I'm not gonna
tell you that Judith is alive just yet
because it will play better if you're
surprised so instead I'm going with a
basic you better come take a look at
this cliche without any explanation
whatsoever man the reunions in the last
three minutes of this show might seem
touching to someone who actually watched
the last four seasons
talk to him not just yet right because
why would you give pertinent information
that you had that would be um batty
since the group is now walking away from
terminus why would the site be pointed
back toward the compound instead of for
approaching strangers
roles on Versalles the then bookends to
this episode or some of the most useless
bookends to ever book in especially
considering
the only information we learn has
already been fully expose ative to us
during the Battle of candle hall it's a
cookbook I'm father Flanagan I'm a man
of God and you must trust me when I say
it's very likely that we're all going to
die it's not for the faint of heart you
definitely need to want to be that [ __ ]
to wear these type of shades okay
look at me can I do that